I was sent some problems by
one of the viewers out there.
I believe his name is Cortagio
or Cortajio, I apologize.
I'm sure I'm mispronouncing it.
But they are really
interesting problems.
What's interesting about them
is that they don't involve
super-fancy mathematics.
They just involve an elegant
way to apply fairly
simple mathematics.
So, without me talking too much
about the problems, let's
try to solve one of them.
Actually, I don't know where
I'm going to categorize this.
Either in algebra or in the
brain-teaser playlist,
or maybe both.
So, an officer on horseback
starts at the back of a column
of marching soldiers and rides
to the front of the column.
Then turns around and rides
to the rear of the column.
If the rider travels three
times as fast as the column
moves, and the column is 100
meters long -- OK, I think we
have enough information
to start drawing this.
Let me draw the
column of soldiers.
I'll just draw this
as a big fat line.
So, that's the
column of soldiers.
I'm about to cough.
Excuse me.
I've learned not to cough
directly in the microphone.
Don't want blow
your speakers out.
So that's the column of
soldiers right there.
And the problem tells us
that it's 100 meters long.
So this distance right
here is 100 meters.
And it's moving with
some velocity.
Let's say, to the right.
So I'm going to just call
it, it's moving with
some velocity, v.
We'll have to stay abstract
there because it doesn't
tell us the velocity.
And then we have the officer.
I wanted to make sure I was
giving the correct title.
So, an officer on horseback
stars at the back of a column.
So he starts here.
He's on his horse.
That's my rendition of the
horse for these purposes, it
has an officer on on the back.
And he is going to, while the
whole column is going forward
with the velocity, v, he's
going to go to the front of it.
Obviously he can go faster
because he's on a horse.
And then he's going to go to
the back and they want to
know how far did this
whole column move.
And how fast is he going?
Let's see, if the rider travels
3 times as fast as the column,
if the column is this traveling
with the velocity v, he's going
to be traveling with
the velocity of 3v.
So let's think
about two things.
Let's think about the time it
takes him to go to the front
of the column, and the
time it takes to go back.
So let's say t1 is equal
to time to front.
And then t2 would
be time to back.
There might be other ways to
solve this, but this is the
way that's jumping
out into my brain.
So let's figure out what
the time to the front
of the column is.
So, over some period of time
-- so, how far is the column
going to move over to t1?
The column is going to move,
well, actually, let me write
a little formula here.
Although I'm sure you
know this formula.
Distance is equal to
rate times time.
Right?
So, over time 1, how far
does the column move?
It's going to move v.
v times time 1.
And how far is this
guy going to move?
Well, we're saying over
time, when he moves to
the front of the column.
So, this whole column is
moving to the right.
And at the same time,
this guy's moving to
the right faster.
So at the end of time 1, which
I've defined as the time
it takes him to get to the
front, what's true about the
officer on the horseback?
He will have had to travel
100 meters further than
the column, right?
In order to catch up to the
front of the column, he would
have had to go 100 meters
further than the column.
So, the distance that the
column travels, plus 100 meters
is going to be the distance
that the officer travels in
the same amount of time.
And what's the distance
that he travels in that
same amount of time?
Well, distance is equal to
rate, 3v, times time, t1.
Time to the front.
So this is a relationship
between velocity and
the time to the front.
And let's see if we can
simplify this a little bit.
So, if we track v t1 from both
sides, we get 100 is equal to
3v t1 minus v t1, that's 2v t1,
and divide both sides
by 2, you get 50.
v t1 is equal to 50.
The velocity of this column of
soldiers times the time it
takes this officer to get to
the front is equal to 50.
Well, that doesn't
solve our problem yet.
We want to know how far
does the column move?
We have two variables
with one equation.
Not helpful yet.
Let's see if t2 can
help us a little bit?
All right.
I'll switch colors to
ease the monotony.
Time to back.
So, now we're in the opposite
situation, where the
guy's gotten here.
He turns around.
I'd argue, immediately.
He turns around immediately.
And he goes back.
With the velocity of 3v.
So, my question to you as he
starts out here, and relative
to him, he's going this
direction at a velocity of 3v.
And the back of the column
is moving towards him with
the velocity of v, right?
So if you think about it, the
back of the column is going to
be approaching the rider
with the velocity of 4v.
When you have two velocities
that are moving in opposite
directions -- if I move in this
direction, at 60 miles per
hour, and you're moving in that
direction at 60 miles per hour.
Relative to me, if I assume
that I'm stationary, you would
look like you're coming at
me at 120 miles per hour.
So that same idea -- this
officer is going to be
approaching the end of the
column, the back of the column,
with the velocity of 4v.
So how long does it take
them to get to the back?
Well, let's see.
His velocity is 4v.
I'll do that in green.
So his velocity is 4v.
That's how fast he's
approaching the back
of the column.
And it's going to take him
time 2, times time 2.
And his distance, he's going to
travel 100 meters, because
that's the length
of the column.
Is equal to 100.
And let's see, if we divide
both sides of this by 4,
we got velocity times
time 2 is equal to 25.
And, once again, we have 1
equation with two unknowns.
It doesn't help a lot.
Let's review the problem again
to see if somehow we can use
this information and this
information to solve what
they're asking for.
So, they want to know how far
does the column move by the
time the officer arrives back
at the rear of the column.
So, they want to know how far
did this whole thing move over
the entire time of this
problem happening?
What was the entire time?
It was t1 plus t2.
That's the entire time. t1 to
go to the front, and then
t2 to go back to the back.
So how far did the column move?
Well, the column, distance is
equal to rate times time.
So the column will move its
distance -- is equal to the
column's rate, velocity.
And then what's the time
that this whole little
problem occurs on?
Well t1 is how long it
takes the officer to
get to the front.
Plus t2.
So this is what
we're solving for.
This is what we need to know.
We need to know the distance
traveled by the column.
And, once again, we have
all these variables.
But maybe we can do
something interesting.
Let's look at this.
So what is -- so if we just
distribute this, we have
distance is equal to v
times t1 plus v times t2.
And do we know what
these things are?
Well, sure.
We were able to kind of stumble
our way into into what
these values are.
And that's what's interesting
about this problem.
We never figured out v.
We never figured out t1 or t2.
But we can figure out
this whole thing.
Because v times t1 --
they tell us, is 50.
So we can substitute
it back here.
So the distance is equal to 50.
Plus, what's v times t2?
Well, we solved it here when we
figured out how long it would
take to go back to the
front of the column.
So that's 25.
So that, we'll put over here.
So the total distance that the
column traveled is 50 plus
25 meters, or 75 meters.
And this is a neat problem,
because they didn't tell us
how fast the column
is actually going.
They're just saying it's v.
They just said that the
officer is going 3 times
as fast, but we don't
know absolute velocities.
But we were still able to
figure out, even without even
knowing the absolute times, we
were still able to figure out
the total distance that
the column travelled.
Anyway, I hope you
enjoyed that.
And if you did, you can thank
Cortagio for the problem.